there are new warnings this morning
about foodborne illness across the
country health alerts have been issued
for more than two dozen varieties of
salads and wraps from several large
retailers including Walgreens Trader
Joe's and Kroger federal officials say
beef pork and poultry salad and wrap
products may have been contaminated
meanwhile health officials in Ohio are
investigating hundreds of reports of
illness linked to a Chipotle restaurant
a Chipotle location in Powell Ohio near
Columbus closed Monday after customers
wrote online that they felt sick the
local health department says it has
since received 368 reports related to
possible foodborne illness stemming from
the restaurant Niki batiste is here with
the latest in a series of food safety
scares for that chain Niki good morning
good morning so far there are no
indications this episode stretches
beyond this one Chipotle restaurant in
Ohio a civil suit filed against the
restaurant on Tuesday claims one
customer experienced serious and
permanent injuries after buying food
from the store and that several
employees called in sick on Sunday and
Monday my wife kind of just yelled to me
she's like hey there's been people
saying they're getting sick at Chipotle
and I I couldn't believe it
Kevin White is one of hundreds of
customers who reported feeling ill after
eating at this Ohio Chipotle restaurant
forcing the popular burrito chain to
close the store on Monday Delaware
County Health District says the number
of calls related to the outbreak has
been growing since Sunday evening did
you eat at the Chipotle on Saw Mill
swelling to over 150 reports by Tuesday
afternoon right now people are reporting
a diarrhea vomiting muscle aches some
headaches fearing another health crisis
some investors said Chipotle stock
plummeting Tuesday by as much as nine
percent the company has been recovering
after an e.coli outbreak in 2015
sickened at least 60 customers in 14
states
what could this foodborne illness be boy
it I can't think that it would be you
know anything other than Noro
iris food safety lawyer Bill Marler
represented dozens of people who say
they were sickened by to pull a three
years ago how do more than 300 people
get sick at one restaurant could have
been an ill employee it could have been
an ill customer this virus can spread
throughout a restaurant incredibly
quickly while Marlar says Chipotle has
had its fair share of problems he says
the company has taken significant steps
to improve its food safety the fact that
matter is is that they have done a
remarkably good job for as many
restaurants as they have post-2015 I
don't see any reason to be concerned
about eating at the restaurant in
question or other restaurants Chipotle
says it cleaned and sanitized the
restaurant and replaced all of the food
inside before reopening the store
yesterday and as alarming as the
incident may appear to be it didn't seem
to faze customers nationwide the chains
freak walk on national avvocato day was
so popular yesterday it crashed the
company's servers used for online
ordering those are loyal customers I
don't have a guac lover so just
everybody loves reporting guacamole
Thank You Nicki thank you